Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Ausspähen unter Freunden, das geht gar nicht. Man will ja nicht abgehört werden, nicht?
Ja klar ist für die, die Terrorfahndung und so machen nicht gut, wenn alles Ende zu Ende verschlüsselt wird, aber der Kunde will es eben ohne Fehlstelle haben hier.
Logbuchnetzpolitik Nummer dreihunderteinundsiebzig vom sechsten zwölften zwanzig zwanzig. Nikolausi.
Zweiter Advent, Nikolaus, alles hier, geil. Mhm.
Richtig ab hier. Und wir haben euch heute wieder richtig was in den Schuh gesteckt.
Ja, wir haben auch wieder nur Ruten dabei heute.
War da irgendjemand umgezogen und äh gehört ein wenig.
Routen mit O U, wir sind doch. Weihnachts.
So zu sagen, ja. Mit Ruth ähm wir haben Ruth und wir dürfen euch knechten. Schön, ne? Jetzt haben wir alle Nerdwitze schon äh durchgespielt.
Ja und äh wir haben ja jetzt äh unsere Bundeskanzlerin Doppelzitiert eingangs.
Und ich weiß nicht so recht, was ich mir draus machen soll, aber ich finde, ihre Kommentare sind immer irgendwie der Knaller. Also nicht immer, aber oft.
Aber was wollte sie uns denn jetzt damit eigentlich sagen?
Der Kunde will es ohne Fehlstille haben.
Ja, das stimmt. Ja.
Ausspielen unter das hat sie ja auch am eigenen erfahren, ne? Das hat sie auch dem amerikanischen Präsidenten mehrmals gesagt und äh insofern ist das ja relativ klar,
Ja, Angela Merkel, meine Güte, was werde ich die vermissen? Also tatsächlich, ich finde auch in in letzter Zeit freue ich mich so ein bisschen, wie mir gucken ja öfter mal auch so Regierungserklärungen an und wieder so, also,
Ich finde da eine eine ganz.
Besondere Faszination. Ich meine, wir haben ja hier gerade im Lockprofil. Wir raten ja eigentlich jede Woche über den Scheiß, den diese Regierung macht, ne. Jetzt mal so auf einer rein persönlichen Ebene in dieser ganzen Pandemiegeschichte. Wenn die da so sitzt und du weißt, die ist halt irgendwie.
Klüger als alle, die da sitzen, hat den hat die ganzen Heiopeis von Scheuer über Söder und wer nicht alles um die rum tanzt, ne. Und die sitzt da seelenruhig, macht ihre Raute, guckt sich das an und haut irgendwie haut denen ihre,
Unsinn mit furztrockenen Kommentaren um die Ohren. Das ist ähm schon auf eine gewisse Weise faszinierend.
Im Lockdown macht man ja wirklich die merkwürdigsten Sachen. Ich habe ernsthaft heute eine Stunde damit verbracht, mir ein altes Interview mit ihr anzuschauen aus dem Jahr neunzehnhunderteinundneunzig, als sie gerade Vizevorsitzende der CDU werden sollte, mit Günter Gaus,
Das ist noch so ein richtiges, altschuliges äh Interview und,
wenn du wenn du mit dem Wissen, wie sie welchen Weg sie danach gegangen ist, dieses Interview anschaust, so, da entdeckst du wirklich eine Menge,
wieder so in gewisser Hinsicht, was man,
sie war eigentlich schon also was ich sie äh hat versucht sie so ein bisschen einzunorden mit na ja also ob denn da die CDU jetzt ein Fehler macht und sie hätte doch irgendwie so wenig Erfahrung, ob denn das irgendwie äh ginge und so,
und man merkt also schon in ihrer Mimik merkt man so, wie sie so das alles erstmal so ein,
passiert, was was er da so zu sagen hat und man so, ja ich.
Schaue mir halt erstmal alles an und nimmt übrigens auch viel Bezug auf ihre äh Physikervergangenheit und Wissenschaftlerische Tätigkeit. So, ja, man,
alles an und wenn man sich da nicht so gut auskennt, dann hört man erstmal zu und guckt mal, was so alle so zu sagen haben und dann wird sich ja zeigen, ob
man die richtigen Entscheidungen wählt oder nicht. Hab's jetzt so ein bisschen para frasiert so. Und äh so völlig absurd so. Du hörst natürlich so ihren Tonfall, der äh war natürlich damals schon der Gleiche, trotzdem blickst du da halt irgendwie in so ein Gesicht, was man locker dreißig Jahre jünger ist.
Also das war schon irgendwie unwirklich, ne, aber man hat schon gemerkt.
Ich will jetzt nicht das Wort berechnend verwenden, aber mir fällt gerade nichts anderes ein. Also sie hat so eine so eine Scanner-Natur, so dass sie halt wirklich erstmal.
Eigentlich ist es die gute, alte äh Methode mit erstmal Schnauze halten und erstmal gucken, dass die anderen sich alle erstmal vergaloppieren und dann kann man immer noch das Richtige tun, so
und das das das hat ja irgendwie hervorragend funktioniert, ne.
Ja, aber man muss jetzt auch also ne, wir haben genug unter dieser äh unter dieser Regierung auch gelitten, gerade im Netz politischen Bereich und so, ne, also das ist.
Ja gut, ich rede aber jetzt nicht von ihr als die Regierung, sondern sozusagen.
Genau, aber das wollte ich nur nochmal betonen.
Ganz klar.
Person ist die ungeschlagen also das ist so wenn jetzt auch noch politisch sauber wäre, würde man hier fast noch 'ne Amtszeit gönnen. Aber ja es ist wirklich irrsinnig und sie hat.
Also diesen, diese Ruhe,
die hätte ich auch gerne. Ich könnte diese Ruhe, ich kann die in meinen stärksten Momenten vielleicht mal für wenige Sekunden haben, aber spätestens, wenn ich irgendwie Horst Seehofer den ganzen Tag um mich rumtanzen hätte, dann würde ich irgendwann die Nerven verlieren, ja?
Und das äh geschieht ihr nicht. Die denkt sich halt, die lehnt sich zurück und sagt, oh komm, du tanzt dich auch noch platt. Wobei, bei dem hat sie's nicht geschafft, ne, der.
Na ja, das ist halt Kalkulation, das ist eben ihr Machtspiel. Das hat sie irgendwie ganz gut äh raus, ne? Aber in gewisser Hinsicht kann man ja auch nicht vorwerfen, dass sie sich nicht nicht klar,
positioniert. Also es kam dann zum Beispiel auch so die Frage nach ja äh hier Wendezeit und irgendwie die ganzen demokratischen Bewegungen. Dann meinst du nur so, ja diese ganzen basisdemokratischen,
Bewegungen soll es wäre ja nicht so ihr Ding, ne,
so wie ja wie damals total so wie Demokratieaufbruch, was nicht alles. Ja die werden alle so unorganisiert, ne.
Ich kann mir vorstellen, Merkel so beim Plenum.
Merkel beim Plenum.
Bam. Macht echt nur so Festival und denkt sich so, Leute, ihr redet euch hier einerseits um Kopf und Kragen und zweitens kriegt ihr nix auf die Kette. Ja, ich hör mir lieber alles an, mach dann so meine Entscheidung und dann haue ich das raus und dann nächst.
So und das da muss ich auch echt sagen, also wie hieß es früher so Chapeau-Kanzlerin.
Ja, aber Tim ist jetzt auch gut ekelig hier, ey. Wir machen jetzt.
Irre wem ihre Gebührt. Ja.
Ja, das äh ist, ist so, wir wollen aber jetzt.
Wir können sie ja erstmal loben und dann hauen wir wieder drauf. Ist auch ein.
Wie die Bild-Zeitung. Wir schreiben die jetzt hoch und dann schreiben wir die runter.
Viele Leute waren bass erstaunt, dass die Tickets zur RC drei ausverkauft sind, wie der also ich meine, wenn es schon Tickets gibt, dann und die nix kosten, dann kann man, hätte man vielleicht,
daran denken können, dass die potentiell, dass es daran liegt, dass die Begrenzungen haben, aber äh okay, ähm.
Hätten wir auch wahrscheinlich dranschreiben können, um es nochmal klarer zu machen. Aber ja, die äh Tickets sind ausverkauft, aber es gab einige ähm,
sagen wir mal, äh wie nennt man das?
Verwirrung darüber, was jetzt überhaupt ein Ticket ist und wozu das berechtigt. Die wichtige Nachricht, die Streams werden offen sein, wie immer. Also auf jedem Chaos-Event gibt es,
Ich glaube tatsächlich auf jedem Chaos-Event gibt es Livestreams und diese Streams sind öffentlich im im Free IP,
ähm empfangbar ohne Werbeunterbrechung,
und ähm das ist natürlich auch bei der Remote Kawas Experience wird das so sein. Ähm,
wenn man allerdings in Workshops möchte oder eben quasi in den Communityteil, der jetzt die Begegnung unter den Leuten nachbilden soll und die Möglichkeiten bieten, die wenigen Möglichkeiten bieten soll, die uns geblieben sind.
Um da reinzukommen, benötigt man eben ein Ticket. Und es gibt jetzt sicherlich einige Leute, für die das total wichtig ist, die unbedingt rein wollen und wahrscheinlich auch einige Leute, die denken, ach so, diesen Community, da brauche ich eigentlich gar nicht. Ähm,
können dann zum Beispiel auch gerne ihr Ticket weitergeben, ja? Ähm wenn sie jetzt sagen, ich wollte eigentlich nur so ein bisschen Stream gucken, das könnt ihr ohne Ticket.
Das wollte ich an dieser Stelle nur so sagen. Gleichzeitig ist die Orga so wie ich das höre, gerade äh bemüht.
Zu gucken, ob man für diesen Community-Teil noch mehr Ressourcen schafft, um somit noch mehr Leute da,
mit einem Ticket segnen zu können, aber da weiß ich nicht genau, wie wie das bei der Orga gerade aussieht. Das ist ja alles,
Freiwilligenarbeit und äh ja auch harte Arbeit, denke ich, muss man sagen.
Na, vielleicht sollten wir nochmal so kurz an andeuten, woraus sich dieser Event dann letztlich also speist, ne, also neben dem
Content teil, der so ein bisschen versucht, die Fehlstelle zu ersetzen, die ein ausgefallener Kongressnummer so mit sich bringt, sodass eben bestimmte wichtige Themen
einfach noch rübergebracht werden. Das ist so ein bisschen Content-Bespaßung, äh gibt so ein bisschen Hirnnahrung, wie man das eigentlich zum Ende des Jahres
üblicherweise eben vom Kongress gewohnt ist, werden solche Vorträge aus, ja, im Kern zwei Quellen, also entweder,
Weiß nicht ganz genau, wie es gehandhabt wird, inwieweit teilweise was voraufgezeichnet ist oder live gemacht wird. Ähm zusätzlich gibt's ja dann auch noch die Idee,
zu haben, wo Bühnen sind, wo auch noch solche Vorträge stattfinden können,
inwiefern die jetzt die verschärften Lockdown-Anordnungen überleben werden, wird sich zeigen.
Ja, die Bayern haben sich zum Beispiel gerade äh also Söder hat ja jetzt da nochmal Verschärfungen.
Beschlossen und da kam jetzt grade 'ne Mail aus Bayern noch an die also sagten so ja wir können dann eben unsere Stage die wir geplant haben werden wir einfach nicht durchführen können.
Ja, das kann auch noch andere Bundesländer treffen, also machen wir uns nichts vor, das ist alles andere als gesichert,
So und nebenbei gibt es dann eben noch diese reine virtuelle Community Welt, in der sich halt einzelne Gruppen so ihrer äh,
durch die man dann halt äh grafisch durchtigern kann, Leute treffen kann und dann werden halt auch so,
oder kleine Workshop Videokonferenzen zusammengeschaltet und das ist halt das, was eben konkrete, lokale Ressourcen braucht.
Und da der Club halt an der Stelle nicht sich irgendwie Computer bei Amazon kauft, wie ihr euch das wahrscheinlich vorstellen könnt
versucht das eben einfach aus eigener Kraft, mit eigener Infrastruktur, mit offener Software und so weiter auf die Beine zu stellen,
ist es eben in gewisser Hinsicht erforderlich, hier so ein äh Andrangsmanagement zu betreiben und dafür sind halt diese Tickets.
Jetzt jeder, der so ein Ticket hat, dann auch diese Ressourcen, von denen man ausgegangen ist, so in Anspruch nehmen wird. Das sind Erfahrungswerte, die jetzt eben,
erste Mal so in der Form überhaupt nur gewonnen werden können, deswegen ist das halt alles so ein bisschen über den Daumen gepeilt.
Heute hat die Orga noch so ein Blogpost gemacht von dem virtuellen Aufbau, wo sie äh sagen, also hier in dem, na also in dem
Community teil, kann man äh Veranstaltungen, Workshops anbieten, mitgebrachte Projekte teasern, seine eigene Essenbly halt äh virtuell verwalten
Räume anlegen, ja, Videochat und sonstige Sachen und sammeln, also wenn man jetzt da, ne, quasi bestimmte
Aufgaben erfüllt oder so, dann kann man da halt ein Badge bekommen und dann hast du am Ende eben in deiner virtuellen RC drei World äh bestimmte Auszeichnungen gesammelt. Da sind auch einige Bilder.
Einer, ja, zwei D Welt, die äh ganz spannend aussieht. Ja, dass man sich da offenbar,
in einer 2D-Welt bewegen kann, die dann irgendwie ein bisschen äh.
Offenbar in irgendwie in Videostreams oder sonstigen mündet. Das sieht auf jeden Fall mal ganz spannend aus, aber ich kann natürlich so viel verraten, da sitzen natürlich auch Leute, die jetzt gerade,
ob dieses Großexperiment, was dann eben am siebenundzwanzigsten zwölften starten wird, natürlich auch so ein bisschen mit den Knien zittern, ob ob das alles.
Eben auch hält.
Alles genau, alles wird sich zeigen. Wir sind hier, was hinter dieser ganzen Sache, mit dieser RC drei steht, ist eben unter allen Einschränkungen, die es gibt. Trotzdem ein Community Event zu schaffen in dem Wissen.
Dass das kein adäquater Ersatz für das sein wird, was wir normalerweise im Winter machen, sondern allenfalls eben.
Das Beste auf Bäumen gegen die,
Vernichtung der durch durch Krankheit und Einschränkungen und Sichttum und Pandemie,
was äh uns irgendwie möglich ist mit Hilfe des Netzes, ne? Also je nachdem, womit man das eben vergleicht, wird man das eben sehr schön finden oder eben sehr äh enttäuschend finden
Ich hatte ja, glaube ich, hier schon mal gesagt, wer das eben mit einem Kongress vergleichen wird, äh hat sich ein Rezept dazu geschaffen, äh wahrscheinlich sehr unglücklich zu sein. Und wer das mit
ähm vielleicht sonstigen Zuhause sitzen, vergleicht wird hoffentlich eine interessante Welt finden, in der sich Austausch mit.
Gleichgesinnten und interessierten Menschen ermöglichen wird, denn da haben wir wenigstens das kleine bisschen im im zwanzig zwanzig auch noch gehabt. Ich denke, das ist so die.
Die Erwartungshaltung, die man mit der man daran gehen kann. Nun ja,
Ach so, genau, Merch. Ich habe ja, ich habe ja, ich fühle mich ja immer wie Karl Lagerfeld, ne.
Äh ich habe heute gar nicht mehr reingeschaut, aber ja, heute ist der sechste zwölfte, das heißt heute endet diese Phase mit dem.
Wo wir also morgen wird quasi dann geordert und angefangen zu produzieren. Äh wir werden ein bisschen mehr bestellen, das heißt, in den nächsten Tagen wird's wahrscheinlich noch ein bisschen Reste in diesem Shop geben, aber der wird
zeitnah geschlossen werden. Also wenn ihr da noch irgendwie Shirts haben wollt oder so, dann ist es jetzt einfach zu spät.
Müsst ihr euch jetzt jetzt hingucken, jetzt gucken, ob's noch gibt in eure Größe. So, genug der der Dinge in eigener Sache.
Nee, kommt noch mehr, ne?
Ja, wir haben ja.
Wir haben letzte Sendung gar nicht erwähnt, dass äh der Verkehrshamster für uns von Max,
Würde ich sagen, wird das ausgesprochen gezeichnet wurde. Den haben wir, habe ich aber dann noch direkt in die Sendung mit eingefügt in die. Also einige von euch haben den vielleicht im Podcast-Player gesehen.
Ansonsten sei er nochmal ähm hier verlinkt.
Und dann haben wir ein sehr ausführlichen und lesenswerten Kommentar bekommen von Matthäus Gordon zum Thema,
YouTube-Universum. Ich muss ja tatsächlich zugeben, dass ich da nicht so drin ähm verkehre in dieser ganzen YouTube-Welt,
Ich weiß aber, dass es sehr viele Menschen gibt für die im Prinzip YouTube die gleiche Hintergrundbeschallung ist, wie jetzt irgendwie Podcast, Radio oder nebenher laufender Fernseher,
und die da sehr viel äh sehr viele Youtuber kennen.
Ja, das ist nochmal so eine eigene Community, muss man auch sagen, so. Also YouTube viel benutzen tue ich auch, aber äh richtig in so eine,
Welt da noch mit abzusteigen und die angesagten Shows so verfolgen, das äh erfordert noch mal so eine gewisse ähm innere Härte, die wir, glaube ich, so nicht aufbringen.
Ne, genau, aber hier Matthäus Gordon hat also da sehr viel zu geschrieben. Ich der Commentar ist wirklich lang, ist verlinkt, ich zitiere jetzt meinen Auszügen.
Ähm hallo Herr Timm, ich stimme euch zu, dass Ken Jepsen ein Coronaleugner ist und man die Unruhestifter, die versuchen, die Krise für ihre Zwecke auszunutzen, irgendwie zügeln muss. Leider verlinkt ihr,
News, ein neues Outlet der Annette KH-Näh-Stiftung, die früher Stahlsee-Mitarbeiterin war,
Diese Aussage zitiere ich jetzt hier einfach nur, habe ich nicht geprüft, ich gebe das einfach nur mal weiter, ähm halte ich für,
nicht nennenswert relevant, aber der nächste Punkt ist, ich hätte auffallen können, dass der Artikel sehr tendenziös ist. Würde ich jetzt zu anmerken, Kenny Japson hat macht auf mich auch den Eindruck, recht tendenziös zu sein. Aber ähm,
Matthias Gordon klärt auf. Es wäre zum Beispiel erwähnt worden, dass der Empfänger der antisemitischen E-Mail,
die ähm also hier dem Ken Jepsen vorgeworfen wird, Hendrik Broder war, der sehr ähnlich tickt wie Ken Jepsen,
Klammern neu rechter Spinner, aber eben in der Israel-Lobby,
hätten die Alarmglocken läuten können. Damit ist das Bild nicht so schwarz und weiß, wie es vielen Zuhörern erscheinen mag. Es gibt viel Grau. Jepsen hat viele Kritiker,
israelischer Politik interviewt, die sich für die Rechte der Palästinenser einsetzen.
Die rechtsradikale Regierung oder eben die Zionisten kritisieren, zum Beispiel Rolf Verleger, ehemaliges Mitglied des Zentralrats der Juden oder Evelyn Hecht-Galinski, Tochter eines Holocaust-Überlebenden. Er hat auch Professor
Professor Moschel Suckermann, Zuckermann, interviewt. So, also.
Israel Palästina Konflikt. Zum Glück sind wir Logbuch Netzpolitik und nicht Logbuch Konflikt. Insofern halte ich da jetzt komplett,
jede Bewertung raus aber,
Ich denke, es ist klar, dass ähm Henrik M Broder üblicherweise auch nicht ja, lauter äh arbeitet in,
persönlichen Auseinandersetzung, auch wenn ich das auch das alles jetzt nicht verurteilen kann. Ich gebe das nur wieder. Aber ähm das finde ich eben auch spannend an dem Kommentar von äh Matthäus Gordon R,
entwickelt das auch. Und sagt dann so, Kenn FM hat sich erst so richtig negativ verändert, seit Ende zwanzigneunzehn, was auch mit der Änderung des YouTube-Algorithmus zusammenhängen dürfte. Ich spekuliere
Da haben sie gemerkt, dass sie vom Algorithmus belohnt werden, wenn sie, wie Trump-News auftreten und damit ihre Reichweite vervielfachen können.
Weitere Auslastung. Diese negative Veränderung von KenFM wird von manchen langjährigen
benutzt, um ihre alten Vorwürfe zu erneuern, die damals genauso wie heute nicht unbedingt zutreffend waren. Ich habe jedenfalls lange Jahre Interviews von angeschaut, weil ich durch die sehr interessant, durch diese sehr interessante Menschen kennenlernte.
Dafür sah ich über seine persönlichen Schwächen hinweg. Niemand muss sich auf seine konfusen Reden anhören und meiner Meinung nach ist er ein sehr schlechter Redner. Man muss auch sehen, dass es bei ihm eine Entwicklung gab, die sich
in den letzten Monaten erst zum schlechten beschleunigt hat. Weitere,
springen wieder ein Teil. Insgesamt finde ich die Sperren in Ordnung und überfällig. Es hat nicht nur Jepsen getroffen, sondern auch eine Menge schlimmere Hetzer meist aus dem rechten Spektrum um AfD oder schlimmer, zum Beispiel,
Hagenprell mit seinem grandiosen supersicheren Webprojekt
Oliver Janich und so weiter. Das sind Internet-Battler, die von den Almosen ihrer Anhänger leben, die sich dafür belügen und betrügen lassen.
Also wie gesagt, der Kommentar ist um einiges länger und klärter erklärt da relativ viel über eben unterschiedliche Youtuber, von denen, da muss ich dann auch ehrlich sagen, ähm,
von einigen von denen habe ich nie gehört, ja, dass äh ich habe.
Insofern klang dieser Kommentar für mich sehr äh informiert und aufgeklärt und offensichtlich mehr Ahnung von Ken Jepsen, als als ich sie habe.
Das wollte ich deswegen wollte ich den hier mal so würdigen. Hast du dem noch was hinzuzufügen Tim?
Also ich habe das äh alles nicht so in dem Maße verfolgt. Gut, ich meine, dass Leute so eine Entwicklung durchmachen,
Ja, das kann man ja bei bei äh vielen sich in diesen Jahren so radikalisierenden Menschen äh feststellen.
Ich habe auch so ein paar, ne,
konkret fällt mir jetzt eine Person ein, mit der ich früher früher viel Zeit verbracht habe und irgendwie gut Freund war, so dann auch irgendwie so an diese Schwulblerszene und Schwubler Demos verloren.
Die haben auch so eine Entwicklung durchgemacht so und.
Wirklich aktiv an die an diese äh Querdenker, an die Schiefdenkerdemos da.
Anti-Corona-Demo so ein Pipapo und so das volle Programm, ne.
Leute, die sich selber als in Anführungsstrichen unpolitisch bezeichnen, was im wesentlichen mit,
Ich habe mich da nie so richtig mit beschäftigt und mir war's eigentlich auch immer egal, äh übersetzen würde, ja, und ich habe da eigentlich auch keine Ahnung, die sich aber dann sozusagen in diesem.
Moment äh ja, ich würde sagen, einerseits von bestimmten Leuten so missbrauchen lassen, ja, aber andererseits das auch so mit ihrer.
Vielleicht vorhandenen Grund esoterischen Denker und äh weißt du, so diese diese ganze Gemengelage ja ich, was kenne ich für.
Für Leute, ehemalige äh Waldorfschulfreundinnen.
Meine Hippies ähm.
Dreht oder was?
Sind sind äh Naturwissenschaftlerinnen.
Die meisten meiner Hippies sind auch äh super. Aber halt nicht alle.
Okay, äh ich ich frage jetzt hier nicht in der Sendung von wem du denn sprichst.
Nein, es ist ja auch völlig egal. Es geht ja nur dadrum ja, sone Leute machen so eine Entwicklung, ja? Und es gibt Leute, die sind da mehr so Opfer,
Ja, weil die einfach
dann einfach nicht diese intellektuelle Staminar haben, sich dagegen zu wehren und die werden dann einfach mitgerissen. Ich denke, das sieht man bei vielen da, ja, dass die einfach auch aus so einer Informationslehre, die vielleicht in ihrem Umfeld besteht, ja
da so mitgerissen werden und dann in so einer verenden.
Und es gibt halt auch welche, die es eigentlich besser wissen müssten und die dann vielleicht von YouTube Algorithmen und äh anderen äh Verlockungen einfach anfangen sich zu radikalisieren und und äh das so lange tun,
bis sie selber dran glauben und dann einfach komplett durch die Decke gehen. Ich meine, auch dieser Attila Hildmann.
Auch ein Freund von dir?
Nein, aber das ist dachte, es wäre dein Freund. Nee, aber ich ich kenne ja nicht, aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, vor zehn Jahren hätte man wahrscheinlich mit dem noch ein normales Gespräch führen können,
vielleicht.
Habe ich vielleicht sogar.
Aha, siehste mal, ist ein Freund von dir, ne? Wusste ich's doch. Deswegen,
beziehst du dich eben auf ihn. So und aber der ist dann halt einfach auch irgendwann weggekippt. Also der macht einfach das Hirn dann auch einfach den den Schalter äh der Schalter wird dann umgelegt,
dann war's das.
Ich muss dazu sagen, also,
würde jetzt gerne, vor allem, weil ich ja weiß, dass potenziell auch Freunde von uns sich potenziell angesprochen fühlen könnten, wenn sie das jetzt hören. Möchte dazu noch sagen, es gibt.
Hier eine sehr klare und das habe ich auch immer wieder betont, es gibt eine sehr klare Position, vieles an der in Anführungszeichen der Coronapolitik.
Zu kritisieren. Was
Förderung angeht, was bestimmt, was Sinn und Unsinn von Einschränkungen angeht, ne, gerade im im Bereich der Schule kann man, glaube ich, ne, wenn die jetzt mit Eltern sprichst oder mit Lehrerinnen, da kannst du über vieles
dich ganz schön beschweren, ne? Muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen und da ähm nicht jede Person, die Kritik an den Einschränkungen übt.
Ist aus automatisch eine schlechte Person oder eine dumme Person. Ähm ne und oder eine Schiefdenkerin oder Nazi oder sonst was. Es gibt aber natürlich eben diese eine Kurve, wo du dann,
Ja, fernab von wissenschaftlicher Erkenntnis oder Ratio ähm,
argumentierst und da bist du dann eben da bist du dann wirklich halt im Aus, ne? Und da da habe ich zum Glück ehrlich gesagt keine,
Freundinnen und Freunde, die soweit draußen sind
Das äh habe ich nicht. Habe durchaus Leute, die ja wahrscheinlich zu einzigen zu einzelnen Maßnahmen andere Meinungen haben als ich und die da auch äh vielleicht laute Meinungen zu haben, aber die würde ich immer noch im Rahmen des,
diese Meinung kannst du haben, ansiedeln, ja? Ähm.
Also man kann über Maß, man kann über alles, was passiert ist natürlich eine eine Meinung haben, solange man darüber auch noch äh halbwegs diskutieren kann, das ist ein
ja, aber ich rede jetzt wirklich von diesem Vollextrem, also wirklich nur noch äh irgendwelche Parolen nachbrabbeln auf diese bekloppten äh äh Demos gehen an sich im Prinzip, damit Nazis gemeinsame Sache machen äh unterm Strich, ne.
Wie diese eine hat mir das nicht hier auch irgendwie und dann gab's doch diese eine Frau, das haben wir hier kurz erwähnt, ne, die dann also wirklich noch so auf dieser Demo live interviewt wird,
Ja, ich sehe aber hier keine Nazis so, während wirklich Liter League in dem Moment hinter ihr wirklich so einer mit mit den äh üblichen Nazi-Emblemen äh hinter ihr, von links nach rechts geht. So und das
Das ist halt so ein bisschen ähm der Punkt, wo ich mir denke so, ja, nee, das muss ich jetzt auch nicht geil finden.
Aber das Problem sind diese Leute, die eben dann auch für sich die Wahl treffen, zu führen
So und da gehört einfach dazu und dann kann er früher noch so geile Interviews geführt haben. Ja, das das hilft dann äh auch nicht mehr. Man kann sie halt einfach nur mit dem bewerten, was sie jetzt gerade tun und das ist halt leider einfach.
Nicht okay.
Aber genau das fand ich hier an dem Kommentar eben auch das äh Bemerkenswerte, dass dass das getan wird,
ja? Und das ist das, deswegen habe ich mir diese Zeit genommen und das auch mal so lange Kommentare oder diskutieren wir eigentlich auch hier in der Regel nicht so so ausführlich, ne? Aber das fand ich mal ganz spannend.
Ähm na ja, okay, kommen wir, kommen wir zur zur anderen Scheiße.
Zum Ausspähen, was gar nicht geht.
Geht nicht.
Also unter Freunden.
Das BND-Gesetz soll ja novelliert werden, ähm,
Der aktuelle Status quo ist ja eben auch bekanntermaßen durch das Bundesverfassungsgericht als verfassungswidrig äh abgeurteilt worden, Lokbuchnetzpolitik berichtete und jetzt,
müssen die eben das Ziel haben, mit einem neuen BND-Gesetz eben diese verfassungsgemäßheit wieder herzustellen. Und da wurde jetzt vor Kurzem.
Der Referentenentwurf herabgereicht, ja und das ist sehr spannend. Ist hundertneununddreißig Seiten lang.
Alte BND-Gesetz, was wir zwanzig sechzehn hatten, war ähm irgendwie,
um einiges kürzer, ja? Oder zumindest nicht so so ausführlich, aber es wird jetzt eben vollständig neu geschrieben. Das Alte hat sechsunddreißig Paragraphen
Davon sollen nur die ersten beiden Abschnitte bestehen bleiben, neunzehn bis zweiundsechzig werden neu gefasst. Paragraphen neunzehn bis zweiundsechzig, wenn äh neu gemacht, das heißt, ne, jetzt eine sehr viel umfassenderes,
Gesetz. Und die Verbände haben also das ist ja dann so die Referentenentwürfe werden gerne mal den
interessierten Verbänden zur äh Kommentierung vorgelegt. Da wird gesagt, könnt ihr jetzt irgendwie was machen. Und dann wurde eine Woche gegeben. Was dann natürlich auch von den Verbänden.
Ähm nicht so grundiert wurde. Ähm.
Und ich habe mir jetzt hier mich äh insbesondere ähm daran gehalten, an die an die Einschätzung von Eco. Und Eco muss man jetzt noch mal dazu sagen. Ecoverband der Internetwirtschaft ist das, glaube ich, ne, für ähm,
wir hatten einen den Vertreter von Eco bei uns in der Logbuch Netzpolitik dreihundert oder was ist die dreihundert?
So lange her, dass wir ein Live-Event gemacht haben. Mit Klaus Landefeld, ja. Ähm.
Kann man eigentlich auch immer wieder äh nochmal empfehlen, diese Sendung und auch insbesondere das Interview mit Klaus,
Internet, Titan, Netzpolitik, Titan und da äh glaube ich zu der Zeit hatten, sprachen wir auch mit ihm eben über diese Klage gegen das PND-Gesetz und so. Ich glaube, da war die noch nicht entschieden oder war die da schon entschieden?
Ihr werdet die Antwort erfahren, wenn ihr die Sendung euch nochmal anhört. Okay, ähm.
Also, ich möchte ein bisschen darauf eingehen, was also in der Ecostellungnahme äh kritisiert wird. Zuerst einmal,
wird der der BND die soll die Rechte eingeräumt werden, Anbieter im Ausland hacken zu dürfen und sowohl bestands,
Verkehrs- als auch Inhaltsdaten ohne Wissen der jeweiligen Betreiber zu erlangen. Das ist also wirklich die Lizenz zum Hecken von,
Telekommunikations- und Telemedienanbietern. Also sowohl irgendwie Mobilfunknetze als auch Clouds wollen die Hecken dürfen im Ausland,
relativ krasse Nummer. Und spätestens, wenn du das im Ausland machst, dann heißt es halt auch wirklich, du musst da hacken
ne? Du kannst jetzt nicht irgendwie bei den Amerikanern sagen, ey Leute, ihr habt ja bei uns auch überall so diese Tabs dran. Vielleicht können wir auch können wir bei euch auch vielleicht wie sieht der aus so, ne? Können wir? Nee, da musst du da, musst du dich da reinhecken?
Und da kritisiert Eco natürlich, ist ja auch eine alte und lange Leier, dafür musst du Schwachstellen haben, diese Schwachstellen musst du geheim halten und damit betreibst du einen Raubbau an der eigenen Infrastruktursicherheit,
und du stehst eben in Konflikt mit anderen Staaten und äh den Grundrechten der Bürger.
Ausspielen unter Freunden, geht ja eben auch gar nicht.
Und dann sagen, kritisieren sie, da kommen natürlich jetzt in diesem Gesetz eine Reihe juristischer äh Hütchenspielertricks, wo dann irgendwie Einschränkungen bei den Inhalten gelten, aber nicht bei den Metadaten,
und diese äh diese Einschränkungen werden aber äh relativ.
Gut umgangen, weil sie eben sagen, diese Metadaten und viele andere Personen bezaubernde Daten werden eben hier normativ in diesem Gesetz als nicht personenbezogen deklariert.
Obwohl sie es sind
Zum Beispiel Verkehrs- und Metadaten von Telefonaten, E-Mails, Messenger, Nachrichten, Surfen, Online-Banking, Navigationsapplikationen, Hotelbuchungen und sagen eher so, wenn das jetzt nicht direkt beim Sender oder Empfänger abgefangen
wird, gilt das nicht als menschliche Kommunikation mit Personenbezug,
Ja, also die deklarieren sich da wieder ganz viel raus in den in den Definitionen haben sie da eben noch einiges versteckt.
Ähm natürlich kennt der Eco das Bundesverfassungsgerichtsurteil sehr genau und da stand drin, sie verlangen, dass die Filterungen, also die,
Filterung nach Suchbegriffen, Wissenschaft dem Stand von Wissenschaft und Technik entsprechen. In dem Gesetz wird jetzt nur vorgeschrieben, dass sie dem Stand der Technik entsprechen müssen. Und das ist natürlich ein spannender Punkt, weil
das heißt einfach nur du brauchst den modernsten,
Wenn es aber heißt, es geht auch um Wissenschaft und nämlich eine wissenschaftliche Evaluation deiner Filter und der Wirksamkeit, dann hat das was ganz eine ganz andere Bedeutung.
Dann gibt es eine gnädige Begrenzung,
auf dreißig Prozent der weltweiten Verkehre früher in einem früheren Gesetzesentwurf waren das fünfzig Prozent und das klingt klingt ja direkt ähm,
wie nennt man das? Moderat, ja? Aber wenn du dir halt mal überlegst, was bei diesen dreißig Prozent der Welt, ne, dann dann steckt der Knackpunkt im Nenner, äh dreißig Prozent der Welt, sind eben ein Vielfaches von der, von den Verkehren in ganz Deutschland.
Und dann machen sie sich noch relativ viele Gedanken eben über die Kontrolle, was ja der entscheidende Punkt dieses BND-Gesetzes ist. Sie müssen sich damit dieses,
dieses Kontrollregime,
auferlegen und da machen sie auch einige Schritte in die richtige Richtung, aber dann sagen sie zum Beispiel bei den schriftlichen Anordnungen, die eben auch kontrolliert werden müssen, nicht die Suchbegriffe genannt werden, sondern nur, was die Maßnahme erreichen soll
Wenn aber die Suchbegriffe nicht genannt werden, dann kannst du natürlich als unabhängiges Kontrollgremium nicht,
diese Maßnahme beurteilen, weil eben Ziel,
Also Sinn und Zielgenauigkeit nicht unabhängig beurteilt werden, ne? Wenn sie sagen, ja wir konzentrieren uns jetzt auf die Taliban,
So, okay, sagst du, ja, nee, das ist okay. Und wenn die wenn die dir aber eventuell dann die Suchbegriffe dazu zeigen, ne.
Und ein Suchbegriff ist Allah oder so, ne, dann kannst du halt sagen, okay, Leute, das könnt ihr so nicht machen. Da sammelt ihr zu viel. Und ähm,
Ansonsten kritisieren sie dann noch, dass mehrere klare Vorgaben des Bundesverfassungsgerichts hinsichtlich von Übergangsfristenzweckbindung und so weiter,
nicht äh berücksichtigt werden. Also.
Eigentlich auch spannend, dass dann dass dann eben dieser dieser unabhängige Verband, den nochmal das die Vorgaben des Bundesverfassungsgerichts erklären muss. Das ist dann schon auch irgendwie ein
schlechtes Zeugnis für das Handwerk, was hier in diesem.
Gesetzesentwurf schlummert und ja, wie gesagt, die Verbände hatten eine Woche Zeit,
Dazu Stellung zu nehmen und noch im Dezember soll dieser Gesetzesentwurf vom Bundeskabinett verabschiedet werden und auf den Weg gebracht werden. Das ist natürlich schon,
relativ stark, wenn man sich überlegte, dass sie sagen, ein Drittel der weltweiten Kommunikation wollen wir abhören, wir wollen Mobilfunk und Internetanbieter weltweit hacken, wir treffen dann irgendwie keine,
wirksame Unterscheidung mehr zwischen Inhaltsdaten, Bestandsdaten und Verkehrsdaten.
Sammeln eben sehr, sehr viel durch die Konzentration auf einen Meterdaten. Ich habe das ja hier oft ähm,
erklärt, dass Metadaten letztendlich sehr schnell sehr viel aussagekräftiger sind als konkrete Inhalte, weil sie sehr viel schneller, umfassender und genauer zu analysieren sind. Ne, Inhaltsanalyse ist schwer. Metadatenanalyse ist einfach,
und ähm mit der Datenanalyse ist sehr viel weniger Daten, die du dafür brauchst, sodass sie da dann eben, wenn sie sagen, ja da erfassen wir nur die Metadaten, dass eben
ungeschulte denken, ach ja, okay, da wird die Kommunikation nicht abgehört. In Wirklichkeit wird aber Unmengen an personenbezogenen Daten erfasst.
Wer hat uns verraten?
Andre Meister schreibt in seiner Bewertung der Geheimdienst, kann die Verkehrsdaten ganzer Mobilfunk und Internetanbieter vollständig auf Vorrat speichern. Ähm.
Wenn er Deutsche, Telefon und Gerätenummern als Klartext speichert. Ja, weil deutsche Daten natürlich unkenntlich gemacht werden müssen.
Bundesregierung ist aber weit weitgehend einig mit ihrem Ding und äh wollen das dann jetzt eben auf den,
auf den Weg bringen. Den Gesetzesentwurf im Volltext hat äh Netzkritik,
Ork natürlich auch wieder äh veröffentlicht daraus zitiere ich auch gerade Andre. Und ja äh noch in noch in diesem Jahr wird das dann jetzt schnell durchs Kabinett und,
weiter geprügelt, werden wir sehen, wohin da die Reise geht.
Telefonnummer als Hashtag ist natürlich eine tolle Idee. Die haben ihre Telefonnummer nicht abgehört. Wir haben nur den Steck benutzt.
Vor allem muss man ja sagen, also ähm eine Telefonnummer zu haschen ist,
nur bedingt sinnvoll. Es gibt relativ viele Telefonnummern, ne, das ist richtig, aber der Raum ist endlich und der wenn du da jetzt Telefonnummern hast, viel Spaß, das kannst du noch knacken,
Also, ne, das kannst also diese Mühe kannst du dir geben, vor allem, wenn du den äh wenn du da jetzt wirklich ähm,
Na, also es ist einfacher irgendwie, ne, das ist ja dann eben nur ähm zehn hoch und nicht irgendwie vierundsechzig.
Hoch. Und ähm deswegen kannst du Telefonnummern hashtag wie du willst, das ist keine wirksame Methode.
Ich wollte hier nicht hashtag so als Hashtag benutzen.
Kannst du auch machen.
Nach ihrer, wir haben nicht nach ihrer Telefonnummer geschaut, wir haben nur nach dem Hashtag haben wir noch einen Lattenzaun davor. Ja. Lattenzaun vorm Kopf haben die.
Wir bleiben immer noch bei der Überwachung, da gibt es ein also wieder ein ein interessantes Gerichtsurteil um.
Tutannothar, ist ein E-Mail-Anbieter mit äh Sitz in Hannover, die ähm ja sagen wir mal.
E-Mail versuchen zeitgemäß zu machen. Wenn E-Mails zwischen ähm tut er Note ähm.
Accounts ausgetauscht werden, werden die automatisch von denen Ende zu Ende verschlüsselt. Und auch kannst du dort halt aktivieren, dass die E-Mails bei denen auf dem Server verschlüsselt gespeichert sind, was eine sehr sinnvolle Maßnahme ist.
Wenn du das mit jedem anderen E-Mail oder mit vielen anderen E-Mail-Anbietern vergleichst, ne? Es gibt relativ viele, die es inzwischen machen, Tutanothe oder es gibt einige, die es inzwischen machen. Tutanuther ist eben einer davon. Und jetzt will aber die Staatsanwaltschaft
Zugriff auf ein E-Mail-Konto haben und Tutanotha hat gesagt, naja dafür müssten wir ja jetzt, also das geht ja so nicht, weil wir haben ja nun mal diese,
ne? Die Leute äh geben ein Passwort an und Keys werden dann generiert und da kommen wir gar nicht dran. Also wir können nicht da dran und sie müssen.
Um das zu ermöglichen, muss Tuta Notha quasi einen gezielten Angriff auf seine Kunden machen.
Das hat äh toter Notar, der hat ihm gesagt, so der geht gar nicht, das können wir nicht machen, das wollen wir nicht. Und jetzt wurden sie aber erneut vom Gericht,
dazu gezwungen, das zu tun. Die hatten schon mal, glaube ich, letztes Jahr Ärger, da haben wir auch äh meine ich darüber gesprochen.
Glaube ich auch, ja.
Und ähm jetzt.
Wird es, werden sie ihm gezwungen, eine Überwachungsmaßnahme für die neu eingehenden und verschlüsselten E-Mails. Bereits verschlüsselte Daten und ohne zu Ende zu Ende verschlüsselte E-Mails äh.
Kann, tut der Notar nicht ähm entschlüsselt, geht einfach nicht, aber sie müssen eben ähm,
Sie müssen, werden jetzt gerichtlich dazu gezwungen, das zu tun. Aktiv ihren eigenen Kunden oder ihre Kundin anzugreifen. Ich habe ja gesagt, es gibt noch andere E-Mail-Anbieter, die das tun. Ähm,
Ich habe jetzt hier gerade den heißen Artikel dazu auf, die nennen die auch, zum Beispiel Proton-Mail, Posteo,
Mailbox ORG bieten das als als Option an, dass du eben sagst, okay, ne, ich möchte, dass die Daten bei euch verschlüsselt werden und dann kannst du auch, wenn ich das richtig in Erinnerung habe, sagen und ich will.
Also standardmäßig verschlüsseln, die den Kiel mit deinem Passwort und du kannst dann eben auch noch sagen, nee, ich will ein getrenntes Passwort für diesen Key haben.
Weil ich euch damit nicht traue, was ihr da tut.
Wann gibt man den ein? Also, an welcher Stelle entschlüsselt man das?
Du loggst, also,
in der in der Basiseinstellung logst du dich ein und mit deinem Passwort wird dann der Key entschlüsselt, der zum Lesen der E-Mail gebaut wird. Ich habe mir die Architektur jetzt in diesen Fällen nicht
grade noch mal angeschaut, aber üblicherweise ist das der Gestalt gelöst, dass der Key verschlüsselt auf dem Server liegt.
Ja? Und der wird dir dann, wenn du dich, es sind ja immer so webbasierte Dinge. Das kannst du ja nicht umsetzen mit, mit iMap und SMTP und oder, oder so, ne? Sondern du,
du bedienst diese äh Dinger aus einer eigenen App oder aus einem Webinterface und das Webinterface,
Gib dir den verschlüsselten Verschlüsselungsschlüssel vom Server,
und du gibst dann eben in dem Browserfenster den das Passwort ein, um diesen Schlüssel zu entschlüsseln.
Okay, also die Entschlüsselung findet quasi im Browser auf meinem Computer statt.
Im Browserkontext bei dir, genau. Und das wären dann eben natürlich auch die.
Entsprechenden Angriffspunkte, die in Java-Skript unterzumogeln, was das Passwort mopst, ähm in Zukunft eben diese Verschlüsselung mit einem zweiten Schlüssel zu machen und so weiter. Wir befinden uns hier genau in,
dem Thema was die Krypto jetzt hier wieder angehen wollen, ne? Anbieter wird gezwungen.
Gegen dich vorzugehen. Und genau das haben wir jetzt hier in einem,
ähm in einem Strafverfahren durch einen Gerichts äh Urteil in Deutschland ohnehin schon. Ja, das ist nicht ist keine gute Entwicklung.
Tut der Note äh wehrt sich natürlich auch da oder also können sich ja jetzt gar nicht mehr so dagegen wehren. Sie wurden jetzt dazu verurteilt, aber sie ähm.
Sagen eben, dass das Urteil,
der kommt jetzt diese kommt die juristische Komponente dich nicht so genau beurteilen kann, aber das Gericht sagt quasi Tutanotha ist ja ein Mitwirkender bei der Erbringung von Telekommunikationsdiensten,
Auch wenn.
Ein Telemediendienst ist und eben deswegen kein Telekommunikationsdienstbetreiber ist. Und aber das Gericht sagt eben ja, aber ihr wirkt ja daran mit und deswegen äh müsst ihr das jetzt auch machen.
Naja, das E-Mail-Konto, was sie da im Zweifelsfall angreifen wollen, liest liest wahrscheinlich auch die Nachrichten und sieht, aha, okay, mein tut da Notekonto ist jetzt vielleicht nicht mehr sicher.
Ich muss mir vielleicht ein anderes Konto suchen, ne.
Das ist insofern jetzt rechtskräftig, als dass sie jetzt schon reagieren müssen und sie meinen, sie würden jetzt bitte Entwicklung der Überwachungsfunktion beginnen, so. Ähm aber trotzdem wird Beschwerde eingelegt gegen das Urteil. Genau.
Beschwerde ein, aber das hat keine aufschiebende Wirkung, ja. Tja.
Nee, das ist also und es, ja, es geht wieder darum natürlich, also in diesem, das ist natürlich jetzt wahrscheinlich wieder irgend so ein Einzelfall, also wenn ich das.
Richtig erinnere ist das eben eine kriminelle Person, die diesen, ja klar, die diesen ähm,
In diesem E-Mail-Account benutzt und wenn ich das da muss ich jetzt sagen, das habe ich nur im Kopf, das steht hier nicht, aber ich glaube, dass die dass die irgendwelche Erpressung oder irgendwie so etwas macht, ja? Keine Ahnung.
Ähm,
dann denkst du dir in dem Einzelfall, na ja, das wäre schon gut, wenn das, wenn die Polizei irgendwie es schafft, dieser Person das Handwerk zu legen, aber wenn du dann eben denkst, so, naja, wenn,
damit eben.
Sicherheitsfeatures aktiv angegriffen werden, die eben die Kommunikationsinhalte dieses E-Mail-Kontos angehen, dann ist das eben ein gefährlicher Präzedenzfall. Und es wird eben leider, das muss man ja immer betonen, eben nicht bei diesen einzelnen Ausnahmen bleiben.
Hier ist auch noch, ich bin mir gerade nicht sicher, hast du das schon erwähnt, also dass die meinen, die Überwachungsmaßnahme betrifft, nur neu eingehende Mails.
Genau, nur neu eingehen, also in der Retrograd können sie das nicht, das ist auch gut, aber ähm.
Ja, sie müssen's jetzt halt für die neu eingehenden machen. Das ist trotzdem schlecht. Ja, es geht um einen Fall von Erpressung. Hat solche.
Tja, ich halte das ehrlich gesagt für unwahrscheinlich also das Ziel der Ermittler soll ja sein, dass sie aus diesen E-Mails, Hinweise
auf die Täter erlangen können, aber wenn die Täter dieses E-Mail-Konto nutzen, um mit ihren Opfern zu kommunizieren, dann wird da im Zweifelsfall auch kein Hinweis auf die Täter drin sein. Aber okay.
Nun ja, dann wollte ich eigentlich nur noch mal zur Corona-Warn-App zurückkommen.
Weil sich zu meinem großen Missfallen inzwischen ausführlich dieser Unsinn manifestiert hat.
Die Corona-Warn-App funktionieren nicht wegen des Datenschutzes. Das wird, ehrlich gesagt, jetzt überall einfach,
problemlos nachgeplappert von irgendwelchen Leuten, die wirklich keine Ahnung haben. Und wenn du die dann fragst und sagst, könntest du bitte,
Oder könnten Sie bitte ein Beispiel nennen, wo die Corona-Warn-App nicht funktioniert.
Wegen des Datenschutzes. Ja, oder spezifisch vor allem die Warnfunktion nicht funktioniert wegen des Datenschutzes. Können sie mir bitte ein Beispiel nennen? Dann bleiben die Personen dieses Beispiel schuldig.
Die haben aber kein Problem damit, das weiter zu behaupten. Finde ich äh wirklich interessant.
Niemand kennt ein Use, wo Datenschutz die Epidemieologische Wirkung dieser App behindert,
Das heißt nicht, dass es mit der App nicht Probleme gibt. Wir haben da ja ausführlich drüber gesprochen, dass Leute Probleme haben durch die App auf ihr. Äh äh Testergebnis hingewiesen zu werden, dass es teilweise Probleme gibt.
Wenn du irgendwie deinen zweiten Test hast und der erste noch da drin ist, dass die App dich nicht einen neuen Test einlesen lässt und so, ne, das Ding ist wirklich ähm nicht frei von Problemen. Aber Datenschutz ist kein Problem.
Ja ähm Herr Lehrer, darf ich mich kurz melden?
Ne. Erinnerst dich noch an unsere allererste Diskussion zu dem Thema mit der Corona-Warnapp?
Da hatten wir irgendwie so als wir sozusagen diese diese Struktur einer möglichen App äh diskutiert haben, also die Grundidee und ähm da ging's ja auch um dieses, so, kann ich,
herausfinden, wo ich jetzt einen Kontakt hatte, ne. Und das ist ja tatsächlich etwas, was aus Datenschutzgründen auch limitiert ist. Das ist, muss man sagen,
nicht unbedingt nur wegen der Corona-Warn-App, sondern mittlerweile eben auch das durch das zugrunde liegende Framework, was eben viele solcher Informationen auch gar nicht erst heraus gibt,
aber klar so diese ganzen Begegnungen, die man so hat, sodass man danach nicht weiß, wann es jetzt eigentlich wirklich war, also das äh das ist äh sicherlich etwas, was man debattieren kann,
Großen und Ganzen gebe ich dir natürlich recht,
sehe ich das genauso, dass die Grundfunktion auf gar keinen Fall dadurch eingeschränkt ist, aber man kann darüber diskutieren, ob man bestimmte Sachen äh lockerer handhaben sollte.
Genau diesen diesen Punkt, den du gerade sagst, hört man,
Am meisten, wenn Leute sagen, ja, Datenschutzbehindert die App, wenn ich eine Warnung erhalten habe, steht da nicht, wo ich war,
Leute, wenn ihr die Warnung erhalten habt, dann hat die App schon funktioniert
und du hast eine Warnung bekommen. Das heißt, irgendwie zu sagen, die App funktioniert nicht, ist in, ab dem Moment, wo du eine Warnung hast, sowieso schon verkehrt. Das, also ne, das muss man halt mal ganz klar sagen. In dem Moment hast du die Warnung erhalten,
per Definition funktioniert.
Ja ich meine ja auch vorher sozusagen, wenn man eben noch nicht wirklich gewarnt wurde, dann diese ganzen Begegnungen hat und dann immer nicht einschränkt äh einschätzen kann, wo man die denn jetzt eigentlich gehabt hat.
Ich, also ne, das ist eine das ist eine ähm das ist eine ähm.
Vielleicht feine Einschränkungen, aber das also der Ort, das habe ich auch immer argumentiert, der Ort ist.
Für den Punkt. Du hattest eine Begegnung und insbesondere die roten Begegnungen unerheblich. Und er ist es erst recht bei den Grünenwarnungen. Ne, also man muss, ich finde, um das,
ganz kurz, ganz kurz, um das Argument zu machen, die App funktioniere nicht, muss man die Funktion verstanden haben. Und die Funktion ist, sie warnt,
und wenn du irgendetwas an diesen Warnungen, wenn dir etwas an den Warnungen nicht gefällt, finde ich das total in Ordnung, das Argument vorzubringen ähm die Warnungen sollten informativer sein oder sonst was. Ist völlig in Ordnung, kann man machen. Ich habe ja auch,
ähm also es gibt eine ganze Menge,
Dinge, die man an dieser App verbessern könnte, ne. Ich habe ja selber auch noch mal einen Beitrag auf Reise geschrieben und gesagt, hier Cluster-Erkennung und so, ne, all das, ne, aber zu also daraus abzuleiten, die App funktioniert nicht, wegen des Datenschutzes, ist eben nun mal leider falsch,
kannst du so nicht sagen.
Wollte ich damit auch gar nicht sagen, ne. Ich wollte nur sagen, es gibt,
durchaus Bereiche, also dieses äh gerade in letzter Zeit so äh diese diese ähm wie heißt das? Ähm diese Begegnung Risikobegegnung, glaube ich, ist die Bezeichnung in der äh App, ja, die sozusagen noch nicht zu einer,
Warnung mit hier du warst in der Nähe von äh jemanden, der sich also infiziert gemeldet hat für ein,
Zeitraum und mit nennenswerter Nähe, ja? Das ist das eine, da hast du natürlich komplett recht
Das andere wäre aber eine hilfreiche Information, wenn man zumindest mal einschätzen könnte, so, oh, ich war diese Woche einmal im Supermarkt und jetzt habe ich irgendwie drei Risiko,
Begegnungen, die allerdings nicht mich jetzt gleich als, gehe mal zum Doktor äh einschätzen,
Wäre schon hilfreich, wenn man so ein Gefühl dafür bekommt, äh bekommen würde, so an welchen Tagen man eigentlich überhaupt auf einmal Leuten begegnet ist, die sich später als infiziert gemeldet haben.
Absolut richtig, aber noch mal hat nicht also das ist wäre schon hilfreich, ist nicht übersetzbar in diese App funktioniert nicht.
Das ist äh einfach eine eine Unsinnsbehauptung und wenn jetzt irgendwie diese Woche einen interessanten äh Austausch
mit äh diesen Zeit-Podcast dann da, die das auch behauptet haben. Und ich dann gesagt habe, das ist leider nicht korrekt. Und dann haben die irgendwie noch behauptet, sie hätten das nicht gesagt. Wo du sagst, Leute
hier ist ein Podcast. Tut mir leid, ich habe da Erfahrungen mit, was der einmal gesagt hast,
kriegst du nicht mehr Fekt. Man musste dann schon zustehen. Und da haben sie irgendwie behauptet, ich würde Unwahrheiten behaupten. Und dann wollten sie irgendwie, wollten sie sagen, ja, funktionieren und warnen oder so wäre ja ein Unterschied. Und es ist wirklich so, es ist,
ich finde es haarsträubend wie ja Leute halt einfach so was,
nachplappern, der Datenschutz ist schuld, ne? Weil wir alle, und das muss wir das jetzt auch gar nicht,
spezifisch auf diese Zeitpodcaster projizieren, weil das eben auch ganz viele andere machen. Und ganz viele andere machen das so ausführlich, dass es selbst bei den in der Regel sehr gut informierten und ähm auch ja
nachdenklichen und sich Zeit nehmenden Zeit-Podcastern
auch schon ja in im Prinzip als wahr übernommen wurde. Ja, dass sie das ja wiedergeben, als wäre das eben eine allgemeine Wahrheit, äh die man auch nicht mehr belegen muss.
Und das empfinde ich dann doch äh recht äh beachtlich für eine,
dann doch eben durch nichts zu belegende Äußerungen, dass die sich in Deutschland so,
ausführlich hält, einfach nur weil ein paar Überwachungs äh Hardliner sagen, ja ich will bei den Leuten in der Wohnung kontrollieren und ich will hier, ich will das wie in Südkorea haben, da hat das mit der App funktioniert, obwohl die
wo sie nicht checken, dass das einfach daran liegt, dass in den asiatischen Ländern die Leute ohnehin einfach verstehen, was Hygiene ist und das eben auch anwenden,
na ja. Also, ich möchte nur nochmal betonen, diese App funktioniert und ähm,
und zwar so gut wie es eben geht
mit diesem Bluetooth Ding und zwanzig Millionen Nutzerinnen. Mit anderen Funktionen für die Clustererkennung und vierzig oder achtzig Millionen Nutzerinnen würde die durchaus besser funktionieren. Mit anderen
Mechanismen für die Testergebnismitteilung würde die besser funktionieren, aber,
in der Regel ist das nicht ein Problem dieses Mess und äh Warnkonzeptes und das bitte ich zu unterscheiden.
Das tun wir jetzt auch.
Du ohnehin, du machst das ja, Tim.
Ja. Gott sei Dank.
Ähm ich wollte nochmal, also warum ich das so ein bisschen ärgert ist, weil wir haben jetzt irgendwie lang genug Pandemie und ich ich finde, ich habe jetzt auch in letzter Zeit gemerkt, dass Pandemie ist ja auch was spannendes
Also ich will man will ja auch darüber lernen, ne? Man will sich dann über Impfstoffe informieren. Man will wissen, was Messenger, RNA ist, man will,
Ja, hier, ich höre dann immer, hier Pavel und dich an, wie ihr über die Zahlen redet und ne, man will das ja auch vielleicht so ein bisschen verstehen. Also habe ich gedacht,
Aber vielleicht hebe ich Hege ich da auch den falschen Anspruch an die Leute.
Ja, wir sind halt so äh immer alles wissen müssen, Nerds, das geht nicht unbedingt immer allen Leuten so. Manche sind auch glücklicher damit, wenn sie nicht alles wissen.
Und naja, die wissen das ja dann trotzdem.
So
Na ja, ansonsten gibt's jetzt noch irgendwie, haben die haben hat irgendein Start-up es geschafft, die fantastischen vier für ihre App zu äh zu begeistern?
Wo sie irgendwie die Daten verschlüsselt an das Gesundheitsamt speichern sollen. Ähm mir ist, ich habe ehrlich.
Fantastischen vier.
Kennst du die? So eine Rappergruppe aus den Neunzigern.
Die kenne ich aber, was hat das mit einer App zu tun.
Ja, wenn du eine Applaunch musst du ja irgendwie einen coolen Influencer haben in einer also die App kommt, glaube ich, aus Stuttgart und da haben sie eben.
So verrückter beim Stuttgart.
Coolsten Stuttgarter, die es gibt.
Oh Mann.
Haben sie die coolsten Schwaben, die sie finden können, genommen und äh da waren eben die fantastischen vier. So und dann ähm.
Bin mir nicht ganz sicher also dass ich wurde von vielen journalistinnen gefragt ob ich diese App beurteilen kann und da habe ich halt gesagt die funktioniert nicht in Berlin kann ich nicht beurteilen.
Aber wenn ich das richtig verstehe, geht das so also die soll,
Prinzip eine datensparsame Ersatz für die Wirtschaft sein. Also die sagen, wir lösen das Problem Zettelwirtschaft. Und,
jetzt muss man natürlich äh um die App fair zu beurteilen, eben sagen, ja, diese Zellwirtschaft ist ja auch eine ähm,
gesetzliche Vorgabe. Ja, der die zu erfüllen.
Ja auch nicht optional ist. Und die sagen eben, okay, hier, ne, wir machen das mit einem QR-Code und in diesem QR-Code sind im Prinzip.
Deine Kontaktdaten verschlüsselt an den Schlüssel des Gesundheitsamtes.
Und du hinterlegst jetzt an der Venue, ja, dem Restaurant oder der Konzert
Fanta Vier-Konzert, dann gibst du denen diese verschlüsselten Daten und die können deine die können deine Daten quasi jetzt nichts entschlüsseln. Du kriegst keine Creepy Anrufe von der Dame am Einlass oder so, ne?
Aber wenn die jetzt dann einen Corona-Fall haben, dann können die diese Daten dem Gesundheitsamt geben. Das Gesundheitsamt kann die entschlüsseln. Und das bekommt eben dann nur in dem Fall vor, wo sie diese Daten weitergeben müssen. Ich denke, das sollte man äh durchaus würdigen, dass das auch ein,
potentiell sinnvolles Konzept sein kann.
Und gleichzeitig liegen die Daten erstmal nur bei deinem Restaurant oder deiner Venue und da werden sie dann irgendwie nach ähm,
vierzehn Tagen gelöscht. Ich glaube, ehrlich gesagt, dass der Satz, die liegen nur bei deinem Restaurant nicht ganz der Wahrheit entspricht. Ich glaube, die liegen eher bei denen in der Cloud, aber das,
ist jetzt nur eine Vermutung. Und ähm,
sie werben eben damit, dass die Gesundheitsämter jetzt eben begeistert seien. Ich kann auch verstehen, dass die Gesundheitsämter begeistert sind, weil die sonst da irgendwie mit diesen Zellen liegen, ne? Ich hatte das ja hier auch schon alles, alle Probleme gewürdigt, Zettel nicht lesen, Lichtleserlich
nicht ordentlich ausgefüllt. Äh Donald Duck war viel zu oft da Essen und so weiter und so fort, ne.
Kann ich verstehen, dass die Gesundheitsämter da begeistert sind. Ich muss aber andererseits auch sagen, ganz ehrlich,
Ich habe nicht den Eindruck, dass die Gesundheitsämter hier die entscheidenden.
Die entscheidende Rolle bei der Eindämmung der Pandemie spielen. Die sind seit Monaten überfordert mit der Menge an Kontaktverfolgung, die sie durchführen müssen.
Und die funktionieren de facto äh nicht, egal, ob sie da auf einem Zettel oder digital bekommen. Und ich glaube, dass die auch viel zu langsam sind und bei dieser gesamten Alarmierung geht es ja eigentlich eben darum, dass es schnell geht,
und bei dieser schnellen ähm Alarmierung habe ich den Eindruck, ist die das Konzept, was die Corona-Warn-App anwendet, eben immer noch überlegen.
Und da jetzt irgendwie schneller die Daten an das Gesundheitsamt Fax zu bekommen. Äh ich würde einfach sagen, das Gesundheitsamt ist da eher das Problem als die Lösung.
So mein Eindruck. Ich weiß nicht, wie du das siehst.
Mir fehlt da der konkrete Einblick um das äh abschließend beurteilen zu können. Ich meine ähm,
ein bisschen einfach zu sagen, die sind das Problem Hauptproblem, denke ich, ist das Verhalten der Leute.
Und äh das führt äh dazu, dass diese Infektionen stattfinden und es ist natürlich äh selbstverständlich, dass,
es ab einem bestimmten Menge schwierig wird. So, ja, Gesundheitsamt ist nicht unbedingt jetzt dafür gebaut für so eine Pandemie.
Man kann natürlich jetzt äh kritisieren, das werden wir jetzt auch gleich noch tun, dass die entsprechenden Stellen nicht äh ausreichend aufgebaut werden,
Aber ist ja dann nochmal eine andere Aspekt der ganzen Geschichte. Also ich tue mich ein bisschen schwer mit so einem äh pauschalen Gesundheitsamt äh bashing. Ich bin mir sicher, da sitzen auch viele Leute, die ihr Bestes versuchen
Nur das Ganze,
Ja, also diese, ich meine, unsere permanente Klage ist, sagen wir mal, diese diese gesamtmentale,
in Bezug auf Digitalisierung. Ja, das ist einfach diese da, da gibt's einfach keine Automatismen. Man man muss wirklich äh den Apparat unseres Staates noch zum Jagen tragen,
So und das äh hätte man sich schon wünschen können, dass das mittlerweile einfach ähm.
Vorbei ist, aber ist halt noch nicht vorbei. So, dauert einfach noch ein bisschen. Andere Länder haben sich da auch nicht gerade mit rumbekleckert. Meine Einschätzung zum Beispiel war, dass dieses.
Notification System, was ja letzten Endes in Kalifornien umgesetzt wurde von Apple und Google,
in den USA mit Begeisterung aufgenommen wird und dort umgesetzt wird. Ich habe noch nicht davon gehört, dass mir auch nur äh als Sechs-Staaten da in irgendeiner Form äh dran teilnehmen,
Also innerhalb der USA äh geschweige denn, dass dass ich da jemals irgendwelche Erfolgsmeldungen gelesen hätte,
Also offensichtlich.
Sind da nochmal ganz andere Mechanismen äh äh kaputt, so, aber man kann jetzt Kalifornien, die das nicht unbedingt grade vorwerfen, dass sie irgendwie einen eingeschränkten Zugang zu Digitalisierung haben. Äh,
Also es äh bleibt schwierig und es wäre auf jeden Fall gut, wenn der Gesundheitsapparat der Bundesrepublik Deutschland oder generell natürlich auch in Europa
hier äh noch weiter den digitalen Weg voranschreitet, damit's vielleicht auch irgendwann nochmal besser werden kann. Aber,
Das ist ja gar nicht so einfach, wie wir gleich im nächsten Punkt sehen werden.
Ja, ich würde noch ganz kurz anmerken, du hast natürlich Recht. Das war halt nicht in Ordnung, von mir zu sagen, dass Gesundheitsamt ist das Problem. Das ist äh nicht, das ist nicht adäquat und nicht zutreffend. Ich wollte zum Ausdruck bringen, ähm,
die Idee, das über Gesundheitsämter regeln zu wollen und denen das funktioniert ab einer gewissen Anzahl eben nicht mehr. Und diese Anzahl haben wir im Moment, ne? Das heißt, wir wir,
können uns nicht mehr und das sagen die Gesundheitsämter ja auch selber, ne, dass sie sagen, so, das Infektionsgeschehen ist so,
umfassend und so viel, dass wir diese Arbeit, diese Kontaktverfolgung nicht mehr machen können. Die ist.
Umso sinnvoller und umso effektiver je weniger Infektionsgeschehen du hast, weil du dann nah daran bist, ähm das vielleicht in den Griff zu bekommen,
Wenn du irgendwann hier die, die Kettenreaktion im vollen Gange hast,
bringt dir das eben nichts mehr, dann bist du, hast du genau das, was wir jetzt auch an den Zahlen sehen, ne, dann kannst du vielleicht mit der besten Möglichkeit, die zum stagnieren bringen, durch deine Arbeit als Gesundheitsamt, aber,
Das eigentliche Ziel und das hast du auch ja gerade genau richtig gesagt. Das eigentliche Problem ist natürlich nicht das Gesundheitsamt, sondern das Virus. Und alles, was,
die Verbreitung des Viruses ermöglicht. Da ist nicht in Ordnung von mir gewesen, da zu sagen, das Gesundheitsamt ist das Problem.
Nochmal auf diese Datenschutzthese äh zurückzukommen. Diese Aussage impliziert ja irgendwie so ohne Datenschutz wäre es irgendwie viel besser geworden. Und das,
bezweifele ich.
Ja ja.
Noch noch viel mehr, ja? Also äh abgesehen davon, das haben wir ja hier in zahlreichen Sendungen schon thematisiert, dass ich der Meinung bin, dass,
da bezweifle ich schon, dass überhaupt eine funktionierende technische Realisierung äh zustande gekommen wäre
da habe ich wirklich meine Zweifel dran. Äh von der Sicherheit mal ganz abgesehen, ja, also Heckereien hätten da stattgefunden
und dann hätten wir sicherlich nicht so Zahlen wie dreiundzwanzig Komma fünf Millionen Downloads der App, sondern vielleicht eher so zwei Millionen Downloads der App und dann hat sich das Thema eigentlich auch schon erledigt.
Ja, absolut. Okay, sagen wir mal,
Also das was wäre denn jetzt so
sich jetzt mal so das RKI anguckt und die Gesundheitsämter und dann hast du hier so eine App, ne? Was wäre denn eine sinnvolle Möglichkeit, jetzt so zwanzig zwanzig, wo würdest du denn beim RKI investieren?
Teint,
In der IT-Abteilung natürlich, weil wenn man sich so anschaut, wie sie damit zu kämpfen haben, Daten ordentlich zu verwalten, rauszuhauen, äh Übersichten zu liefern, Zugänge, einheitliche Standards und Formate. Da bedarf es einer gewissen äh,
äh Pavel hat gerade im letzten UKW davon berichtet, dass äh noch eine Stunde darauf verwendet hat, irgendwie ähm die Daten nochmal richtig zusammen zu bürsten, weil ihnen,
Landkreis in ihren Daten äh auf einmal aufgetaucht ist, denen es gar nicht gibt.
Da gab's auch einmal einen Landkreis Aachen, der existiert nicht. Und ähm so eine Korken.
Könnte man ja einfach mal mehr Stellen beantragen.
Einfach mehr Personal einstellen, das wäre schon mal ein Anfang.
Hat das RKI gemacht? Weißt du was, die haben gesagt, ja, wir hätten gerne achtundsechzig neue IT Stellen.
Ich glaube, es waren achtundsechzig Stellen und davon war der Großteil IT. Das ist nicht in den Meldungen, die ich gelesen habe, nicht konkret quantifiziert worden.
Stimmt, der Satz ist nicht eindeutig, äh aber hier steht seit Jahren warnt der Personalrat des RKI die Politik, die Behörde braucht er dringend mehr IT-Spezialisten.
Doch anstatt der beantragten achtundsechzig Stellen bekommt das Institut nun gerade einmal vier. Ja, kann man auf auf zwei Seiten. Auf jeden Fall, also ich denke achtundsechzig hätten die hätte man denen ruhig geben können,
ja und.
Ich kann mir jetzt nicht also wenn du sagst so, ey, willst du in der, willst du eine neue IT-Stelle im RKI haben, haben die jetzt gerade bekommen? Das eine.
Äh gibt vier neue Stellen. Da kannst du dir aber auch sagen, so hui ui ui, da musst du aber ganz schön schnell deine IT machen. Also, ich meine, das ist gerade der die wichtigste Bude in Deutschland, in in dieser ganzen Pandemiebekämpfung, die haben ja auch ordentlich Daten.
Und ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, ich kann mir überhaupt nicht vorstellen, wie man da auf vier neue Stellen kommen kann,
Also selbst wenn die gesagt hätten, sie hätten gerne zehn, hätte ich gesagt, nimmer zur Sicherheit zwanzig.
Du weißt ja nicht, was für Vögel da kommen und wir wollen ja auch nicht, dass ihr gestresst seid. Vielleicht wollt ihr auch einfach perming machen oder was auch immer, aber vier neue Stellen
in einer Pandemie, wo du irgendwie grade, weiß nicht, wie viel Millionen für irgendeine App ausgegeben hast, da kann ich irgendwie nicht verstehen.
Also das ist mir auch ein Rätsel und ich habe so ein bisschen das Gefühl,
kann das sein, dass das eine Ente ist? Also das das kann doch nicht das kann doch nicht ihr Ernst sein.
Also wir würden ja selber jetzt ohne ohne, dass ich mit diesem Apparat viel zu tun habe, mal so locker zehn Baustellen einfallen, wo mal dringend was besser gemacht werden müsste. Und
in jeder dieser Baustelle kannst du mal locker zwei, drei Leute mindestens gebrauchen,
damit du da irgendwie auch ein Team hast, was äh ein nennenswerter Zeit auch vorankommt,
Und das muss ja auch jetzt keine Stellen für die Ewigkeit sein. Ich meine, könnte man ja zumindest mal für die nächsten zwei Jahre vielleicht mal erstmal.
Schreiben und dann gucken wir mal, was bei rauskommt und Pipapo. So.
Also ich glaube nicht, dass das eine Ente ist, weil ob also auch wenn es von der Welt, beziehungsweise Welt am Sonntag ist, stehen da äh Namen, respektabler Journalisten dran an dieser Meldung und ähm.
Ja, also ja genau, man man fragt sich dann schon, ob das irgendwie so ein.
Erster, zweiter Adventswitz ist oder so, aber ähm ja, der allen.
Der Obmann, der FDP-Bundestagsfraktion im äh Gesundheitsausschuss sagt,
denke ich sehr treffend. Dafür kriegen wir jetzt die Quittung in der Pandemie, die so sind die Meldungen per Fax, telefonische Quarantänekontrolle, die CL-Wirtschaft mit dafür verantwortlich,
Gesundheitsämtern schon bei vergleichsweise geringen Fallzahlen die Überlastung droht. Ja hier nochmal Entschuldigung an die Gesundheitsämter,
wer mit dem Fax arbeitet. Wir wissen natürlich nicht, wie viele Fax Operator die stattdessen jetzt angestellt haben, ne, dass sie sagen so, vielleicht haben vielleicht haben die auch einfach kurz überlegt und haben gesagt, so IT,
Ich habe doch gar kein AT. Machen wir das doch mal mit mit vier Stellen. Das reicht auch für eure fünf Gameboys, die da auf der Toilette liegen.
Der Entwurf kam von der Bundesregierung und ist durch den Haushaltsausschuss gegangen.
Ja, also
wie gesagt, also vielleicht gibt's ja noch irgend so eine Geheiminformation mit einer äh es gibt aber einen anderen Pfad, über den wir die dann äh bestätigen und das läuft nicht über den Haushaltsausschuss und jetzt ist das sozusagen so berichtet worden. Sowas könnte ich mir fast noch vorstellen, weil ich kann mir einfach,
ich kann mir das einfach nicht vorstellen, dass also ich kann mir das einfach nicht vorstellen. Es ist einfach wirklich äh.
Kann ich mir aber die meisten Sachen, die wir hier erzielen nicht, ne, muss ich auch sagen.
Ja gut, ich meine, da da schneidet man sich natürlich jetzt wirklich ins eigene äh Fleisch und ich meine, das ist äh einfach so offensichtlich, dass man hier auch.
Daten und mit Datenverarbeitung, Statistik, Aufbereitung, wissenschaftlicher Aufbereitung äh aber eben auch mit dem Ausbilden von von APIs, Schnittstellen und so weiter, einfach eine Menge,
ähm auch eine Menge Dritte mit ins Spiel bringen kann.
Ja, die derzeit einfach da so stehen. Ich meine, hast ja schon erwähnt, so äh in UKW mit Pavel, der Pavel sitzt jetzt seit seit März da dran, sich diese Daten,
vom RKI zu holen und es gibt einfach so viel,
Low-Hanging Fruits, dass man sich halt einfach wundert, warum da eigentlich nichts passiert. Aber wenn ich dann halt höre, dass sie irgendwie äh,
achtundsechzig oder wie viel auch immer konkret IT-Leute sie jetzt suchen und dann werden ihnen noch nicht mal, ich meine, warum beantragen sie die denn jetzt erst überhaupt.
Auch unklar, ne.
Das äh wir sind im Dezember, ja, ich meine, die achtundsechzig Stellen, die hätten sie ja, was weiß ich, also im März, okay, meinetwegen, aber so Mai, spätestens Juni oder so, ja, da äh äh müsste dieser Bedarf ja dann eigentlich schon klar gewesen sein
und dann ist noch mal ein halbes Jahr vergangen, liegt der Zettel irgendwie schon so lange im Eingangskorb. Ich habe, also es macht mich einfach ein bisschen wuschig.
Ja deutsch ist auf jeden Fall Deutschland.
Ist wirklich nicht sehr digital, kann man nicht sagen.
Ich glaube auch, es könnte echt sein, dass vielleicht haben die per irgendwie Executive Order oder Notfalldekret ohnehin schon mehr IT bekommen und kriegen deswegen nur die vier, das wäre,
Also da hast du schon Recht. Das wäre auf jeden Fall mal eine Hypothese, die man äh zur Ehrenrettung annehmen sollte. Allerdings
wenn das so wäre, dann hätte sich ja vielleicht auch ein bisschen was an dieser Datenwirtschaft beim RKI inzwischen geändert und hat's ja nicht.
Eben, also ich kann nur ein wenig den äh Kopf schütteln und ich kann mir aber auch vorstellen, dass jetzt hier noch ein passender Shitstorm aufzieht, der da vielleicht nochmal nachfasst.
Okay, äh es gibt äh schlechte Nachrichten aus der äh Gesichtserkennung. Ähm und zwar ich habe, darf ich mich noch vor zwei Wochen oder so lustig drüber gemacht? Da hat die Lufthansa irgendwie so.
Gemeldet, jo. Wir bei uns gibt's jetzt hier bald,
Facial-Check-In oder so, ne? Also du, dass du an dem Geld nicht mehr eine Bordkarte zeigen musst, sondern per Gesichtserkennung da reingelassen wirst. Ähm,
so warum
verzollert, ne, also welche Sekunde spart mir das, dass ich dann da im Finger stehe und auf den Flug warte? Völlig unklar, aber äh müssen natürlich irgendwie auch einen modernen Eindruck machen. Und äh haben jetzt gesagt, okay, wir machen hier jetzt Gesichtserkennung beim Einlass zum Flugzeug. Gut, macht
und in dem Werbebild hatten sie Menschen abgebildet, der eine Mundschutz trug. Und ich habe mich noch darüber lustig gemacht und dachte mir so,
Ja also das wird nicht so viel Spaß machen mit dem Mundschutz bei dem Gesichtserkennungssystem
aber die hatten sogar tatsächlich in ihrer Meldung dann schon gesagt, ja, Mundschutz geht, das äh schafft das
äh Gesichtserkennungssystem. Woraufhin ich mir dachte so, okay, wenn der mit Mundschutz noch funktioniert, dann funktioniert das wahrscheinlich auch mit einem anderen Gesicht. Ja, aber jetzt gibt's eine Untersuchung des Mist, äh äh National Institut of Standards and Technology
die am einhundertzweiundfünfzig unterschiedliche Gesichtserkennungsalgorithmen geprüft.
Und haben gesagt, die Besten, die am besten abgeschnitten haben, hatten nur noch eine Fehlerquote von fünf Prozent, selbst wenn siebzig Prozent des Gesichts mit einer Maske bedeckt ist.
Jetzt frage ich mich immer noch, okay, was ist die Fehlerquote? Ist das jetzt die, dass er dich nicht erkannt hat und dir den Zugang verwehrt hat oder dass er dich.
Erkannt hat.
Obwohl du ein anderes Gesicht hattest, ne? Das müsst ihr eigentlich zwei Federquoten immer geben bei einem solchen Test. Ähm aber ähm ja.
Ist auf jeden Fall eine sehr schlechte Nachricht, was das eben ja bedeutet für wie gut diese Gesichtserkennung wird.
Mit gerecht.
Ja, das ist äh dann wahrscheinlich auch gar keine Gesichtserkennung mehr im eiligen Sinne, sondern mehr ein ein Augen- und Augenbrauenerkennung
also nicht im Sinne von Ihres Erkennung, sondern einfach, dass die Granularität ähm ausreicht. Ist die Frage, ob sich da jetzt um dreidimensional erfassende Systeme äh handelt, also die wirklich die das,
das Gesicht, den Kopf quasi dreidimensional scannen.
Dreidimensional, ja, machen sie. Also bei der Lufthansa, bei diesem Algorithmus, den die bei den Algorithmen, die geprüft haben, weiß ich das nicht.
Genauso, weil rein zweidimensional ist natürlich immer deutlich im Nachteil, man man kennt das ja, vielleicht äh bei den neueren iPhones, da ist ja im Prinzip auch so ein drei D Scanner mit drin, der halt auch noch ganz andere,
Kriterien abklopft, ne? Also das ist nicht nur ein visueller Eindruck,
sondern ähm eben durch diese, wie nennt man das, diese Lichtpunkte, die halt ausgesehen ist, so quasi so so Laser, die äh einerseits halt eine,
äh eine Form berichten, andererseits auch in ihrer Streuung auch ein Material äh,
zum Besten geben können. Also man kann Haut und Stoff und so was zum Beispiel unterscheiden, weil es das Licht anders streut und so eine Geschichten.
Das ist schon alles ziemlich äh haarsträubend. Die Technik wird da äh sehr schnell sehr viel besser.
Deswegen an dieser Stelle nochmal darauf hingewiesen, es gibt das Bündnis Gesichtserkennung stoppen, äh Reclam your face EU mit der
Petition eben diese Entwicklung und den Einsatz dieser Technologien zu stoppen, kritischer zu hinterfragen,
und ähm denke, da kann man sich durchaus mal daran beteiligen und,
ähm dort mitzeichnen, weil das wirklich eine ja Hochrisiko-Technologie für die Grundrechte ist, wenn sowas jetzt einfach massenhaft ausgerollt wird.
So, damit sind wir langsam so am am Ende der Sendung, aber ich habe ähm mir ist aufgefallen, vielleicht so ein bisschen Themenfremd, aber.
Ich habe ja hier äh äh immer mal wieder in der Sendung auch ein bisschen vor den psychischen Folgen von dieser ganzen,
Einschränkungen, Social Distancing, Quarantäne, Isolation und so weiter,
gewarnt und habe äh ja hier öfter mal gesagt, okay, gebt euch bitte, ne, denkt daran, irgendwie Aktivität aufzubauen, denkt daran, ähm aus irgendwie geregelte Tagesabläufe zu etablieren, um eben
so seelische Gesundheit zu wahren, gerade hier in so einer Wintersituation, die ja ohnehin scheiße ist, ist dann halt noch so eine tödliche Pandemie und zu Hause in der Wohnung bleiben echt so risiko für für schlechte Laune.
Und Schlimmeres. Und da ähm hat jetzt das Max Plank-Institut für Psychiatrie,
haben die schon im März zwanzig zwanzig rausgegeben. Ich bin jetzt erst drüber gestolpert. Na ja, ähm sage ich trotzdem, verlinken wir das nochmal. Mir ist ist überhaupt nix Neues. Ähm aber es,
beinhaltet so viele von den Empfehlungen die ich auch gemacht hatte ne? Macht das an geht an die frische Luft, bleibt zur,
macht von mir aus irgendwelche Workouts zu Hause und ähm ja, das äh deckt sich mit den Empfehlungen, die ich ja auch schon so ein bisschen hatte, aber ähm sei hier nochmal.
Äh empfohlen. Was kann ich tun? Aus dem Bett kommen, Tagesstruktur, positive Aktivitäten, Bewegungen,
wie kann ich in Kontakt bleiben? Wie kann ich soziale Schwierigkeiten lösen? Ja und so weiter. Ist noch.
Buch Netzpolitik hören.
Hören. Ja, wenn eins gegen Depression hilft, dann jawohl jede Woche schlechte Nachrichten, ne? Das ist Resilienz. So wird das aufgebaut.
Wenn ihr psychisch durch die Pandemie kommt, wisst ihr schon warum? Hätt's uns mal nicht gegeben. Tanzen sähe es ganz anders aus.
So und dann haben wir noch ähm unsere Freunde von frag den Staat.
Ähm haben einen Job äh anzubieten. Die suchen eine volljuristin.
In achtzig bis hundert Prozent Stelle ab Februar zwanzig einundzwanzig. Für unseren Bereich der strategischen Klagen. Die strategischen Klagen von Frag den Stadt besprechen wir ja hier immer wieder. Ich glaube, das letzte Urteil, was wir da besprochen haben, war
der äh dieses Urteil zum Glyphosat-Gutachten und äh da suchen sie also eine Volljuristin, um sie,
in diesem Bereich zu verstärken und eben im Bereich der Informationsfreiheit ähm hier und der Informationsfreiheitsanfragen äh sich in der Regel eben.
Gegen.
Ja die Institutionen über das Recht, was wir eben durch das äh Informationsfreiheitsgesetz haben gegen störrische Institutionen durchzusetzen.
Also ich weiß ja nicht, wie wie wie spannend oder unlangweilig so andere Jura-Jobs so sind, aber da ist bestimmt sehr unterhaltsam.
Da ist unterhaltsam, ich glaube also erstens ein Bereich der in dem man eine Expertise aufbauen kann, wo es wo sie noch nicht so viele haben und zweitens wurde eine Menge Spaß haben kannst und es immer die Richtigen trifft, ja? Das kannst du ja, wenn du in der Juristerei unterwegs
bist du auch nicht immer von dir behaupten.
Sie sagen, Weiterentwicklung unserer Strategie zur Durchsetzung der Informationsfreiheit in Deutschland und auf EU-Ebene, ja? Eigenständige, rechtliche Betreuung einer Vielzahl strategischer Informationsfreiheitsanfragen und Erarbeitung von Widersprüchen und Klagen im,
Informationsfreiheitsrecht mitbezügen zu Grund- und Menschenrechten, zu Geheimnisschutz, Urheber und Datenschutzrecht, rechtliche Prüfung von Veröffentlichung und Kampagnen unter anderem anhand von Persönlichkeitsrechten.
Auch sehr schön, finde ich auch sehr gut. Umfassende rechtliche Beratung des frag den Staatteams. Da sie also auch noch ordentlichen Bedarf, kann ich mir vorstellen, dass sie.
Ja, da haben wir also umfassenden Bedarf rechtliche Prüfungen, Ausgestaltungen von LegalTec-Anwendungen, unter anderem für automatisierte Widersprüche und Klagen. Vorbereitung von Stellungnahmen im Rahmen von Gesetzgebungsprozessen.
Wir kooperativ wie kooperieren mit vielen Gerichtsanwaltskanzleien und stehen im ständigen Austausch mit mit der juristischen Fachwelt,
innerhalb des Teams arbeitest du eng mit dem Head of Legal sowie mit der frag den Stadtprojektleitung zusammen und bist gegebenenfalls,
zuständig.
Glaube ich, ist ein cooler Job für äh jemanden, die sich im Bereich der Juristerei, vor allem auch irgendwie so ein, ja, ein Profil aufbauen möchte.
Ja und im neuen Themenfeld sich ja etablieren will. Ich glaube, das ist ein cooler Job.
Hätte ich gar nicht gedacht, dass man, wenn man Jura studiert, so coole Jobs kriegen kann.
Gesucht. Paragraphen Ninja.
Ja, okay, ist äh haben wir äh hier auch empfohlen und wer äh sich damit aus, wer einen Eindruck davon bekommen möchte, wer dann,
Der Projektleiter ist ist Arne Semsrott, den hatten wir auch. War das auch in der LMP dreihundert? Nee. Auch dreihundert oder?
Hatten wir da auch, ja. Ah, ich weiß es. Ja, ich komme jetzt auch langsam ein bisschen durcheinander. Ist auch alles schon so lange her. Das war damals, weißt du das alles noch Leute, so in so Räumen, ja. Damals dann ist's her.
Ich gucke mal, Arne Senf Logbuch.
Ähm ja genau, LMP zweihundertsechsundfünfzig war das, äh zehntausend Leute auf eins Komma drei Stellen.
Genau. Ist also auch nochmal empfohlen. Haben wir unsere alten Folgen noch mal empfohlen. Ist doch auch eine feine Sache. Und damit kommen wir, denke ich, zum zum Ende. Ist ja Weihnachten. Also nee, Nikolaus ist heute, ne?
Hast du heute Nikolaus? Warst du der Nikolaus heute, Tim?
Ich bin immer der Nikolaus.
Mir gibt's jeden Morgen volle Schuhe.
Ähm.
Im Podcastform.
Es ist ja Ende des Jahres und einige von euch müssen vielleicht noch zur Begradigung der Steuererklärung geldlos werden.
Oder des Gewissens.
Genau, das ist ja beides, beides braucht regelmäßige Entlastung, ja und ähm da habe ich mir überlegt, man kann ja nochmal ein bisschen daran erinnern, wie äh wohin ihr spenden könnt.
Damit es vielleicht in Logbuch Netzpolitik erstens weiterhin Nachrichten gibt und zweitens vielleicht auch mal mehr gute Nachrichten. Und da hätte ich jetzt spontan drei Organisationen auf der.
Auf der Liste. Das ist einmal auf jeden Fall frag den Staat, haben wir ja gerade schon mal erwähnt und erwähnen wir ja hier sehr regelmäßig. Ist in den Shownotes verlinkt,
Spendenmöglichkeiten an, fragt den Staat. Chronisch unterfinanziert und sehr wichtiges Projekt. Ähm.
Dann denke ich auf jeden Fall an unsere Freundinnen und Freunde bei Netzpolitik Org, die jetzt ja auch am Ende des Jahres immer so ein bisschen Jimmy willsen.
Hilfe.
Mit mit so einem großen Banner, was dann runterkommt, aber machen sie ja ganz nett, sagen, ja, wir finden die Banner auch scheiße. Nee, machen sie nicht mehr, steht da jetzt nicht mehr dran.
Haben sie schon genug Geld?
Fehlt halt noch Geld um das Jahr.
Auf die auf die auf die Null zu drücken, wo es hingehört. Schaffen sie in der Regel auch, weil es im Ende des Jahres einen größeren Spendenrun gibt und sagen natürlich auch, das was wir immer sagen, schön sind natürlich eben,
Spenden, mit dem man kalkulieren kann, mit anderen Worten eine einmalige Großspende ist gut, eine dauerhafte,
monatliche Großspende ist besser. Und ja, dann denke ich, kann man, kommt man in diesem Bereich nicht umhin nochmal auch für die Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte zu werben.
Die ja in diesem Jahr war, wieder ich kann gar nicht sagen, wie viele Verfahren, die wieder angestrengt haben. Julia Reeder äh macht da jetzt eben ihre äh Resozialisierungsmaßnahmen nach dem äh sie,
Europaparlamentsabgeordnete war und ähm.
Die Gesellschaft eingeglie.
Langsam in die Gesellschaft integriert und war ja auch bei uns regelmäßig oder ist regelmäßig bei uns zu Gast und hat auch über ihr Projekt bei der GF
ähm bei der GF hier uns Auskunft gegeben und das da denke ich, da ist das Geld auch ähm sicher und gewinnbringend,
angelegt. Das wären jetzt so die, die mir spontan eingefallen wären.
Oder heil uns.
Ja oder oder also wenn ihr wenn ihr da nichts hinschwimmt, so wir nehmen das auch, ne? Also bevor das Geld schlecht wird oder ihr davon wieder irgendeine Scheiße kauft, gebt das uns, dann kaufen wir davon Scheiße.
Ja, also ich habe schon langsam wirklich ein schlechtes Gewissen. Ich habe schon schon lange nicht mehr so viel dieses Thema aufgebracht wie in den letzten Wochen, aber das halt einfach durch diese durch diesen Kontowechsel einfach dringend. Ähm haben auch schon,
na ja gefühlt fünfundsiebzig Prozent schon getan, was eine bemerkenswerte äh Zahl äh finde, also ich hab's jetzt nicht genau ausgerechnet, aber so so in etwa und das heißt, es ist noch ein,
gewisser Weg zu gehen, aber der wird auf jeden Fall mit äh gegangen, ne. Was äh,
wo in den Spenden LNP drin steht, das geht sozusagen auch hier in das äh Projekt und wird geteilt und ja, das.
Nicht. So ist das nämlich.
Mehr als nur LNP, ne.
Das ist auch richtig, genau. Ihr könnt also, wenn ihr an die Meta-Ebene spendet, unter LMP mit drin erwähnt, dann kriege ich einen bescheidenen, ein, ein Kickback von Tim.
Wie heißt denn dieser Satz, den man bei Amazon äh dran schreiben muss? Bekomme ich eine Provision?
Genau, ich habe hier so einen so einen großen Eimer mit so Beulchen und dann nehme ich immer so eine Schippe Beulchen und das kriegt er dann am Ende des Jahres zugeschickt. Also.
Filiate Spende. Ihr könnt an die Ayurveda Ebenen eine Affiliate-Spende machen. Kriegt einen eine kleine Provision. Ne und.
Ist gar nicht so klar die Provision.
Nein, das ich mache doch nur Spaß. So und wenn ihr ähm.
Nur an die Meterebene spendet, dann könnt ihr eben, also damit könnt ihr, wenn ihr nichts dranschreibt, dann geht's eben an Tim. Und äh genauso habe ich ja auch irgendwo so eine ähm Spendenmöglichkeiten angegeben und wenn ihr dahin spendet, geht's nur an mich.
So haben wir das aufgeteilt. Und damit kommen wir eigentlich auch zu einem weiteren Punkt, weil es eben so viele Spendenmöglichkeit unterschiedliche Spendenmöglichkeiten gibt. Und ich ja nur Teile davon sehe.
Ähm kommt es leider immer wieder zu äh Unregelmäßigkeiten und,
Missverständnisse, wenn ich hier in der Sendung danke. Das Problem ist, ich denk ich danke natürlich nur für das was ich eben auch regelmäßig sofort sehe,
und bei einigen Sachen ist das der Fall, bei anderen nicht und das heißt, es gibt eben auch für euch, die sagen, sie möchten uns unterstützen, eben kein qualifizierendes Merkmal, wofür euch gedankt wird und wofür nicht.
Und äh dass es eben unfair und problematisch.
Und ähm deswegen möchte ich ähm dass in Zukunft lieber persönlich per E-Mail machen.
Und ähm wenn ihr dafür sorgt, dass ich von euch höre oder eure E-Mail-Adresse habe, dann,
danke ich euch lieber persönlich als in der Sendung, weil ich da jetzt, glaube ich, zu oft das eben zu Missverständnissen geführt hat und das ist dann wirklich auch nicht die Art von ähm,
Ungleichbehandlung oder undank, die ich irgendwie Leuten äh zeigen möchte.
Deswegen, wenn ihr mir etwas mitteilen möchtet, denn oder wenn ihr,
ja von mir hören möchtet, dann seht zu, dass sich eure E-Mail-Adresse oder eine Kontaktmöglichkeit habe und dann bedanke ich mich einfach direkt persönlich bei euch, ist vielleicht eh viel schöner.
Ist immer ein bisschen schwierig, ne. Ich meine, ich könnte natürlich jetzt hier anfangen und irgendwie die Kontoauszüge vorlesen, aber das ist.
Wollt ihr das hören? Ich weiß ja auch gar nicht, ob Leute das wollen,
ähm und äh klar, es gibt so YouTube-Kanäle, die ballern dann halt irgendwie drei stumme Frames voll mit mit tausend Namen und Abspenden und so weiter. Hm.
Haben wir halt nicht.
Wir sind euch schon dankbar. Das kann ich euch äh versichern. Sehr und ähm das äh ja, hat auch zu.
Menge Material geführt in diesem Jahr und äh so geht es dann halt auch einfach weiter. Ja, weil es gibt keinen Grund, aufzuhören, ganz im Gegenteil. Wir fühlen uns sehr ermutigt und äh machen eine Menge Spaß dabei.
Es wäre ja schön, wenn wir einen Grund hätten, aufzuhören. Also der einzige Grund wäre, es passiert nichts mehr, ja, aber.
Etwas weniger Wahnsinn, so ein pandemiefreies Jahr, in dem irgendwie.
Keine Aufreger sind?
Wäre doch mal nicht schlecht.
Da würden wir uns ja langweilen, dann bräuchten wir auch nochmal hier so einen psychischen Beratungsdokument irgendwie für Podcaster, die sich nicht mehr aufregen können.
Aber ich kann ja mal eins noch sagen, was äh ich was mich eigentlich, womit man mir eine sehr einfache, sehr große Freude machen kann.
Und das ist tatsächlich, wenn ihr unseren Podcast weiterempfehlt, in eurem äh Freundes- und Bekanntinnenkreis, Bekanntenkreis, das ähm,
fände ich sehr nett, wenn ihr uns neue Hörerinnen beschert. Hm wir haben ja hier einige,
Faktoren, die uns da, sage ich mal, ein bisschen einschränken. Wir verzichten auf Spotify als Kanal. Wir verzichten auf Audible oder wie der andere da heißen. Das ähm,
ist schon auch spürbar.
Und ähm insofern würde ich mich freuen, wenn ihr den Leuten das Evangelium des richtigen Podcasts weiter.
Dezentral, nein, dezentralen Podcasting. Das ist alles. Du hast einen Feed, den du abonnierst, das ist auch nicht zu viel verlangt, ja? Und das ähm das ist schön, wenn ihr dieses Evangelium weitertragt und uns empfehlt, damit macht ihr mir,
eine äh besondere Freude und das äh ja, kann ich tatsächlich sagen, da das das äh wünsche ich mir sehr. Da freue ich mich sehr drüber.
So, jetzt ist es aber auch genug und äh wir bedanken uns fürs Zuhören und äh wir hören uns aber auch nochmal dieses Jahr. Noch ist er nicht vorbei.
Noch ist er. Noch ist der Brand nicht gelöscht.
Nee, das auch. Vielleicht auch dieses Jahr nicht.
So. Und ich danke, ich danke an dieser Stelle, das muss ich jetzt nochmal Dennis, Sabine, Jan, Mark Oliver und Paul, vielen herzlichen Dank.
Die letzten können sich jetzt sozusagen glücklich schätzen, die letzten gewesen zu sein.
Ich denke, ich höre damit dieses Jahr auf. Ich werde mit Ende zwanzig zwanzig werde ich damit aufhören. Ich muss das hier auch ein paar bisschen öfter ankündigen, damit sie dann auch vielleicht auch alle verstanden haben.
Oh, okay. Das heißt, wir machen jetzt diese schneiden diesen Spendenblock jetzt einfach die nächsten Sendungen einfach mit rein und täglich grüßt das Murmeltier. Hm, bis bald.
Ja, so. Bis dahin. Ciao, ciao.